الان العلاقات الدوليه تبدو عشيه تحول
كبير
في اقطابها
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم الرئيس الصيني يصل
موسكو ويؤكد خلال مباحثاته مع نظير الروسي
اهتمامه بتطوير العلاقات والشراكه
الاستراتيجيه
وتنقال ان خطه بيجين بشان الوضع في
اوكرانيا تلقى اهتمام الروسيا في حين وصفت
واشنطن الخطه بغير المقبوله وقالت
اوكرانيا انها تنتظر من الصين استخدام
نفوذها على روسيا لانهاء الحرب
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي يصف الوضع في تونس بانه سيء
للغايه سياسيا واقتصاديا ويقول ان تصريحات
الرئيس قيس سعيد تجاه جنسيه افريقيه في
بلاده غير مقبوله وفي وسط العاصمه
التونسيه حراك مؤيد للرئيس سعيد ندد بما
وصفه بالتدخل الاجنبي
وفدان الحكومه اليمنيه وجماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين يتواصلان الى اتفاق تبادل
للاسرار خلال مباحثاتهما في سويسرا مصادر
يمنع قالت ان الاتفاق شمل
706 من الحوثيين مقابل 181 من اسرى
الحكومه والجماعه تقول ان الاتفاق سينفذ
بعد ثلاثه اسابيع
برشلونه يقترب من التتويج بلقب الدوري
الاسباني لكره القدم عقب فوز ثمين على
ريال مدريد بهدفين لهدف واحد في مباريات
الجوله السادسه والعشرين من المسابقه
ليبنى بذلك تشافي الفوز الاول له في
الكلاسيكو الذي اقيم في الكاميرون الى
اللقاء